The design support library
has a built in fab widget.
It already has ripples and
elevation enabled.
But it's a good exercise
to wire up one yourself
to see what's been done for you.
We're going to create this app.
It has two fab widgets.
One we've created by hand, and one
that uses the design support library.
So I've gone ahead and
created a new project and
selected the Blank Activity option.
In my build.gradle file,
I've made sure to add the design
support library as a dependency.
At the core of a fab
widget is an image view.
We can make life a little bit
simpler by using an ImageButton.
I've set the background to
use the accent color, and
a plus button as the source image.
Fabplus is a vector
drawable I've created.
You could use an image with transparent
images, but it's more scalable to use
a vector drawable because they can
be resized without any quality loss.
As you can see here,
our button isn't very circular.
We can do that by setting
it's background to be a shape
shaded in our accent color.
Now is also a good time
to set our elevation.
Because we use the background drawable,
Andriod can use that data
to calculate a shadow.
We don't need it in this case, but
you could create a custom outline
provide to control how shadows are cast.
You can see more information about
that in the instructors notes.
So going back to our button,
we have a button that we can click and
that has elevation but
it doesn't have any ripples and
it doesn't raised to our touch.
Let's go ahead and add a ripple.
To enable ripples, we need to change the
buttons background from a static shape
to one that's enclosed in a ripple tag.
The color control highlight is the color
applied to things like ripples,
list selectors, etc.
The main difference
between oval_shape and
oval_ripple is that the ripple
tag encloses our shape.
The next thing we need to do,
is add a material reaction to the fab
widget to raise it up to meet our touch.
To do this, we'll add a state list
animator to run an animation when
the user touches the button.
In the layout,
we reference a file fab_raise,
that lives in the resources
anim directory.
We have two object animators, one for
when the button is pressed and
one for when it's released.
Notice how we animated the translation
Z property of the button,
rather than the elevation.
The final elevation is calculated by
adding the current value of translation
Z to the base elevation we set in code.
So this translation Z property
goes from a value of 0 to 8 dps.
Now if we remember, our fab button
has a resting state of six dp.
So it's going to actually go
from an elevation of 6dp to 14.
You won't generally need to
implement fabs from scratch and
you definitely should
use the design library.
But it's likely that you'll need to
create custom widgets that you'll
need ripples for or elevation changes.